hello everybody my name is Roland Huell
aunty young as we say in a in Amsterdam
I already see some familiar faces in the
audience I was supposed to wear boxing
gloves today because New York is a very
tough game for Dutch tastemakers but
anyway I'm going to tell you a little
story my first company was called wild
horses crazy enough but I wanted to
explore the unknown without the
boundaries of what had already been
established and before I'm going into
like the details of my platform I first
want to pay my respects to all the
innovators and tastemakers that are in
the room today so I launched 52 grams
about a year ago we started out as a
curation platform for fashion savvy
instagramers even before Instagram
launched their online profiles
themselves pretty innovative the next
web set but then I thought there needs
to be more to it right if we really want
to add value this is not enough so what
we started to do is allow our users to
actually tag product and connect their
content with products for other users to
discover the items they loved and were
inspired by and that was kind of the
start of a rollercoaster I'm now I'm not
a fan of rollercoasters but I had to do
it anyway there are three things today
that I would like to highlight about 52
grams calm first of all what we
essentially do is we leverage social
content for commerce right and I do not
necessarily care about all the content
that lives on your social media profiles
I care about the content that actually
adds to the online social experience of
your audiences because we think with our
platform that we can truly leverage that
content for commercial success the
second thing the second thing that I'd
like to highlight is that we work with a
few user groups so first of all we do
support brands and retailers to
integrate user-generated Instagram
on their product pages we support them
in doing hashtag campaigns and yes we
support bloggers and magazines to
monetize their Instagram photography by
showing what products are being featured
allowing them to earn a return through
affiliate partnerships Thank You Dallas
what is most interesting is the
ecosystem that actually exists between
these user groups so while working with
brands retailers bloggers and magazines
we recognize that there's an ecosystem
and that all of these user groups can
actually leverage leverage each other
strong suits which basically means that
we automate the process of using each
other's content for and audiences for
commercial success which basically means
that when a blogger or a publisher posts
content Instagram photography with
product from a particular brand the
brand will get a notification and they
can actually push that content to their
audiences using the authentic style
authority that publishers claim on the
other end for bloggers and for magazines
it's incredibly interesting because even
though brands and retailers are looking
for bloggers for increased exposure the
brands themselves most the time have the
biggest reach themselves and that is
interesting to publishers because they
can push their content to a much wider
audience
increasing the ultimate return that they
can enjoy there's one last thing that
I'd like to highlight about 52 grams
komm research has shown that Instagram
is a very powerful platform for content
creation but when it comes to social
interaction and when it comes to
communications people still turn to
Facebook 78% of the people still turn to
Facebook for communications and social
interactions with their peers in the
brands that
love but we also know that a end users
experience on Facebook doesn't really
stretch beyond the timeline so how do we
actually use that platform to gain
commercial success well we had a dream
and our dream was to make sure that end
users could interact with your content
on their timelines and click-through
straight to the pages and e-commerce
sites where they could discover product
specifics and that's what we did
we are proud very proud to kind of
announce here today that we have
launched interactive timeline images on
facebook which means that end users can
click straight through your e-commerce
sites from their timelines and just
imagine that Tommy Hilfiger with 7
million users the revenue that's up for
grabs now to wrap it up there are
Cowboys out here brave enough to explore
the unknown and I'd like to tell and
highlight to all of you in the room
today that don't hire them but partner
with them I'm not looking to be a vendor
I want to be your friend because the
people that innovate today are most of
the times small companies and we can
only innovate if we approach the future
hand-in-hand with established companies
thank you
are there any questions no questions at
all people leaving already
no questions anybody please do there's a
question there's a course no no okay
well give rolling to warm an applause
thank you so much for the nearest
question over there
yeah my answer to that question is that
I personally believe that there are too
many communities out there and people
only have the mental capacity to kind of
handle only a few of them that's why we
don't want to be a community but rather
be an enabler and I think that Facebook
with their kind of established
footprints has become a home for people
and they'll always return to that place
I do think that major social media
networks such as Google+ with major
budgets behind it might be able to kind
of join the game but otherwise it's a
very tough game to get people away from
their homes and well to add to that
answer I think Facebook made a very
strong move to purchase Instagram
because what we see today is that
conversations become highly visual and
that's why for example I believe that
when we look at Twitter which is very
still very textual as well needs to kind
of up its game and they're doing it with
vine and with like they're doing it with
twit baked but they need to up their
game to really kind of claim that visual
conversation as well and that's when I
think they all have a strong position to
yeah to level up with them with Facebook
yes question over here do have a mic yes
sorry I was being a bit of a diva about
the mics - do you feel that or what is
your advice rather for brands who are
really honing in on monetizing their
experience with their users on any
platform so that they don't really lose
the essence of their engagement with the
consumer yeah it was actually a part of
what I was going to say before
I don't think purchase or buy now is the
call to action we should look for
because I think purchase is more of a
consequence of the ability to discover
so I think as brands protecting our
image we Rotter chutes allow our
audiences to seamlessly discover product
specifics because that is what they're
asking for and if we are owning that
process in the seamless and powerful way
then I think we have a recipe for
sustainable commercial success yes any
other questions
well Thank You Roland thank you